my name is anos G I'm going to tell you
about how stars are born and how we know
that like uh I'm an astronomer I don't
know who of you is and so I want to not
just say I don't want to just say what
the result is I want to show you how we
get there uh and that means that some of
the things I show you are not going to
look nice and that's because in practice
research data doesn't usually look like
this sometimes it does and that's
fantastic but often it
doesn't so I'm going to tell you a said
what stars form I tell you how you know
that and I'll tell you a little bit
about how we actually work like the
social part of being an astronomer how
does science come together like how do
we get that data those types of things
because I find that that's often what
people what people like to know and I
think it's really interesting and it's
important of how it goes together but
when you read you know the New York
Times about some great new discovery
it's not going to be in there the pretty
picture is going to be in there the the
disc discover Discovery will be
described that but how people actually
got there is usually not in that so I
want to tell you that so how do St for
this is the r nebul Cloud an optical
picture of the r nebul Cloud zoomed in a
lot obviously and then for some of these
pieces like like this tiny dot here and
uh this if I find my mouse this tiny dot
over there zoomed in even more and I'm
going to show talk about all these
elements in a little pieces I just want
to tell you that star forming regions
are one of the things that look
fantastic now uh to orient you a little
bit about what we are talk what I'm
going to talk about here's the cartoon
of of the faces of star formation stars
form I showed you the picture of the
rular cloud in these huge clouds of gas
and dust and these huge clouds of gas
and dust exist in our Milky today
specifically if you go travel to the
saan hemisphere and you look at the
Milky Way at night there's these black
patches in the sky and that's not
because there's no stars actually you
see that on that image on the wall over
there too that's not because there's no
stars it's because there's clouds of
cold gas and dust in front of us that
cover up some of those stars and when I
say cold gas and dust I mean about 20 to
100 Kelvin so that'll be like minus 200
Fahrenheit and when I say dust it's it's
like if you lick your finger and go like
this over the furniture that hasn't been
cleared that's actually pretty similar
or do it outside often on this dust
there's water ice on it so if you go
outside right now and you just grab a
snowball and fizzle it up that's
actually pretty similar to what these
clouds of gas and dust in the universe
are and then because these clouds all
depend on little pieces right gas
particles and dust clums and gravity
contracts gravity like all these little
pieces pull on each other so they
contract towards the middle now they
don't always go like to the same Clump
but they could go to multiple clumps um
and so you form this in a cloud you form
these these these smaller Clump pieces
and these Clump pieces start Contracting
and as they start Contracting they get
like what we call an inner Co and then
what happens is when you compress
something it gets hot if you uh go and
fill up your bicycle with a hand
pump and after your tire is full you
touch like the valve or you touch the
front of the pump it's going to be hot
that's because every time you compress
the air it heats up
and so the same thing happens here and
eventually it gets denser and denser and
denser and eventually it's going to hot
enough that it starts shining if we can
see
it uh so that'll be like this inner this
inner bit here or this inner star here
now these gas clouds these clouds of gas
and dust they're never stationary
there's always flows there like abs and
not tights but there's like flow over
here and flow over there and there's a
big massive heavy star there that pulls
material up and so when you you compress
it from 200,000 astronomical units to
just one astronomical unit the same
thing happens as if somebody on the ice
like pulls the arms in or if you want to
speak physics angular momentum is
conserved and so like a tiny motion over
here gets a really fast spinning Motion
in the middle and because we have this
really fast spinning motion around these
Central objects you form a
dis and these discs are the reason why
the planets in our solar system all
orbit around the sun in the same way in
the same plane because they all formed
in this disc if was random you you could
have one planet go this way and one
planet go this way and one planet go
that way but that's not what we see
because they're all formed in this disc
that rotate and all rotate pretty flat
around the Sun there's a little bit up
and down because it's not not exactly
flat but essentially all orbit in the
same plane and so these are the disc
where planets form and that's part of
why it's interesting because we want to
look at how planets
form um there's also out flows as I'll
show you and then we'll get these rings
and gaps here and eventually we'll end
up after maybe 50 million years or so we
end up with a system with a star in the
middle and a couple of planets around
and so the phase I work on is like is
like this phase from
here over here to maybe here I'm looking
at how this disc and the Stars
interact why do we care um now maybe you
think that's cool and I think that's
cool and I think it's interesting
but specifically when I write a funding
proposal and say dear NASA please give
me $200,000 so I can keep working on
that I need to have a slightly better
explanation than it's cool right so one
of the things we be care for is the
origin of planetary systems how do
planetary systems form it all how do you
make planets and in order to understand
that we need to know what the conditions
are is it hot is it cold is it is it
dense is it is it iron is that is that
hydrogen what what actually is the stuff
made
of we can also interpret that is going
back in time because we can't see today
how our earth was formed because that
was 5 billion years ago but we can take
a telescope and look at Stellar systems
where earthlike planets are forming
today and so that looking at those
systems helps us understand what the
conditions we have when the earth was
formed and how how potentially life on
on earth started and things like that
and one um one one interesting tidbit or
aspect is that we think or one idea is
that or at least certain
biomolecules may have formed in space
first and then come to on come onto the
Earth Frozen in as comets not
necessarily like a you know don't think
of a don't think of an animal walking
but think of amino
acids and we know that in these large
clouds of gas and dust using radio
observations we can identify fairly
complex molecules like originally people
found you know Carbon then they found
carbon monoxide then they found carbon
dioxide but we now have we found benzo
rings so six carbon atoms in a ring with
stuff around it we found molecules that
have three benzol rings on it so I don't
know I don't work on radio I don't know
what the latest one is but the
complexity of chemistry in these clouds
is astonishing and so almost certainly
some of that rain down on the earth is
that important to start life on a planet
I don't know but it's certainly
interesting that it's there and that the
buildings blocks don't actually or some
of the building blocks
don't don't necessarily have to form on
a planet because they're out there in
space and they're just rain out and so
again for that to understand if that's
important or if that's cool if that's
useful we want to know a little bit more
about the conditions of how stars and
planets form so how do we do that well
we go and look and when we go and look
we have a choice in how we look we have
the entire what we call electromagnetic
spectrum the thing that's most used to
us is visible light right that's what we
detect with our eyes but there's a whole
range out there and the visible light is
just this tiny bit of area of the
spectrum it's just this tiny thing here
there's UV light there's x-ray light
there's gar ray light there's a huge
range of infrared light there's
microwaves there's radio waves already
said in radio we can identify these
molecules and by building the right
telescopes and the right instruments we
can get a lot more information than if
you were just looking invisible
light here's a on Earth demonstration
why that might be interesting these are
two animals right meia cats and
freshwater crocodiles observed in two
different veles the top one is visible
how you would see it with your eye and
the bottom one is an infrared camera and
you see that although they look fairly
similar and have a fairly similar color
invisible light that look vastly
different in the infrared now I'm not a
biologist but if you look close enough
that tells you something about the
temperature of the animal and and the
skin conditions and what the skin is
made of and stuff like that if you look
close enough and so we want to use the
analogy we want to use the same thing in
space by looking at more different
wavelengths to prop more different
properties of uh these things slight
wrinkle many of these wavelengths don't
make it to Earth that's good because for
example x-rays if you have too many
x-rays you're going to get cancer right
if you get x-rays too much so
fortunately uh the Earth's atmosphere
blocks most of the x-rays that come from
space unfortunately for us it means if
you want to see the x-rays that come
from space we have to build a satellite
and fly it above the earth
atmosphere uh that means it's expensive
like the Chandra satellite that I often
work with or that I work for cost about
one to2 billion dollars depending on how
exactly you counted and if something is
broken it's gone it's in space you can't
just fly up and fix it for the Hubble
Space Telescope where they went up with
with space shuttles to fix things every
time you go up and fix something it's a
billion dollars so it's not like you
know you can't just go and and tighten
the screw if you need to so if we can
observe it from Earth that's great but
certain things we just can't because
there's air in between and so the not
incidentally the wavelength that make it
to Earth best are the is the visible
light which is why our eyes see visible
light because we have plenty of that
there but if you want to observe in
several of these other wave bands we
have to observe satellites use
satellites so in x-rays we can use for
example chanra there's a second one
European one called xmm Newton in the UV
the Hubble Space Telescope is still the
best one and this is a picture of the
James web telescope that observes in the
infrared recently seen uh so the solar
panels at Power Chandra the the x-rays
go in here Chandra doesn't make x-rays
it's not an x-ray machine it's a
telescope observes x-rays that come from
space
anyway like the sun makes x-rays black
holes make X-rays and we just need to
see them uh so it's very long chanra was
launched with a space shuttle is
actually the heaviest thing the space
shuttle has ever
launched um and the the detectors are
here in the back
and I can say a little bit more about
how trva is made from or how it was made
later if we get to it okay I said we
want to observe in different wavelengths
because they give us different
information this is a star forming
region that's what people call The
Pillars of Creation in the Eagle Nebula
observed in different wavelengths uh on
the left is visible light observed is
Hubble this is near infrared light and
then on far side is this mid infrared
light so even longer wavelengths and you
see that although the exact same region
you see different
things in for example if when you look
in the optical this hle you see these
dense clouds of gas and dust I told you
stars form I told you stars form but you
don't actually see that because all
hidden behind that cloud when you look
in the mid infrared that D is
transparent and because it's transparent
or mostly transparent you can see all
these Stars here and you can actually go
up and count
them and if you go into the mid infrared
then that dust isn't black it's actually
glowing and because it's glowing we can
now measure the properties of the Dust
We can look at the light that comes from
the dust we can see how much it glows or
what color it has and that tells us what
temperature it has for example and
that's how we know how cold it is I said
it's about you know 100 Kelvin or so
that's how we know and that's how we
know what it's made of yes how do you
know that a star is in the cloud and not
behind it um that's a very good question
there's several several things we can do
uh the easiest
is um that's so so there's complex
answer and not every technique will work
for every one of those Stars one of the
best things or easiest things to measure
distances is you measure you you point
you look at it from here and then you
wait six months until the Earth is on
the other side of the Sun and measure it
from here and there'll be a difference
in angle it's called Parallax and that
difference in angle you can use a sign
and in elementary geometry and transform
that to a distance so that's one way for
example um in this particular case
that's not terribly useful because it's
not that precise and the nebula isn't
that deep but if you can identify the
same star in for example in this image
and in this image then you can say for
example this one you could say there's
lots of stuff behind it lots of nebula I
can't see anything else behind it so
it's clearly in front of like this dense
region and yet I can't see it here so
it's so there must also be still some
material in front of it so it's probably
in the middle that doesn't give me
exactly that it is and it give doesn't
give me a 3D map but it tells me it's
it's not far at least it's not very far
behind and it's not very far in front of
it it's associated with that
cloud in other clusters that are further
that are closer by what you can also do
is you can look at how stars move
because Galaxy rotates stuff moves
around and so when you have one of these
clouds and it moves then all the object
in it should move the same way on the
sky and things that are far away on the
other end of the galaxies aren't going
to move in the same direction we call
that proper motion now of course Stars
don't move terribly fast I mean if you
look out at night you know if you see
something move it's not a star they move
like a typical speed would be um so so
we take a degree right a one degree of
of distance which one degree is about
this much a degree consists of 60 arc
minutes each arc minutes consist of 60
Arc seconds and now I can't do that with
my fingers because I can't make it that
small and then we need it smaller than
that so every arcc we pick down in like
thousand Milli AR
seconds and uh these Stars may move you
know a t of a mli Arc here or so so you
do need some big telescopes and fairly
precise measurements but if you can make
that and there are satellites that are
purpose built for just that purpose and
you see that all the stuff moves
together then they're probably part of
the same
Association I I'll talk a lot about the
Orion nebul Cloud I already told you
some of the things of the r nebul Cloud
so I at least want to tell you that it
is right orine is probably one of the
few things most people can see on the
sky and even Boston you can find ory
because it's one of the few that are
bright enough that you can see that I
know about six conations because I find
that most people I talk to know three so
if you know six that makes you an expert
and that's good enough I don't have
remember any more of that but Orion has
this like popular belt of three stars
next to it and then you have like the
feet and the hands and just down here is
Orion's thought and in the middle of
Orion's thought is this Orion neul uh
this or nebula that I talked before so
the nebul is actually bright enough that
you can see it Vis your bare eye if you
are let's say in Maine or Vermont or in
the moav desert or somewhere it's
actually dark don't try in Boston
pointless
but but in dark spaces you can see
it okay so I already showed you a couple
of images and one of the techniques we
learn about young stars is we do images
of them so here's true real images from
the Orion nebul Cloud I told you that
images that stars have dis around them
how do we know that well here's an image
that looks a little bit like a black
saucer or cigar what that is is is the
nebula behind it is glowing and then we
are looking at the edge of one of those
and the disc is colder and denser than
the rest of the nebula so it makes a
black shadow and so now we can go and we
know how far away orine is and we can
measure the size of this and then we can
calculate the size and kilometers of
whatever unit you want to use
astronomers often use centimeters
although numbers are really high uh we
can calculate the size in centimeters
how long and how thick that is why is
this nebula glowing why is the r nebula
glowing at all it's like driving your
cars through fog it doesn't glow by
itself there's bright stars that shine
light on the nebula and it reflects it
to us so it's a reflection nebula here's
another one uh and what do you see the
glowing stuff here in the middle that's
not the star the star is Tiny the star's
tinier than the tip of the mouse but
what happens is that around this disc
there's other gas and dust the star
can't shines through the disc because
the disc is too thick but it shines
upward and stuff gets reflected and we
see the reflected light
even more obvious here the star itself
sits here in the middle here this is the
black dis left and right it goes kind of
diagonally that we look at from the
side and then this is all gas flowing
out from the star that reflects the star
light and so we can see now which
direction it goes we can see there's
less here which is why it's black
nothing reflects here there's a little
more here we can learn about how gas
flows out from Stars
here's another thing here the star sits
here it has a disc and what you can't
see because there's a cut out way over
here is a very bright star this very
bright star Shines on that disc and
evaporates it it's so bright that
essentially boils off material and then
reflects and shines and so what you see
here is a reflection from this material
that boils off the dis why do we care
well if you want to know how planets
form we need to know how long these
discs survive
like do I have a million years to make a
planet do I have 100,00 years to make a
planet do I have 10 million years to
have a planet and so one thing that
matters is is there a bright star nearby
that boils off all the material and so
we we measure the size of the disc and
calculate the mass of a disc when
there's a bright star nearby and when
there's not a bright star nearby and we
can say Okay bright stars are bad for
making planets at least when you're
close enough and and now I'm saying bad
but of course you could imagine working
out a number and saying the star is this
bright and I'm this far away then it's
going to evaporate X kilograms per
second I don't have that number on top
of my hat I'm not going to bore you the
exact number anyway but you could
calculate that yes in that picture up
there that Center party said is the disc
right and on either side of the disc is
that the young star for me or two other
stars here on either side the bright
lights those those are not the star
itself there's one there's one star
forming here in the middle but you don't
see it because it's behind the disc
behind the it's so if the disc if the
disc looks like this right you're
looking at the edge of the disc and the
Stars here that my by the tip of my
fingers you don't see it but there's
stuff going in and out there's there's
gas and dust on the top at the bottom of
that and so the star Shines on that dust
and it reflects back to you imagine me
taking a flashlight and putting it on
the fog up here you're going to see the
fog or the nebula up and down below even
though there's no star because star
shines in it from the bottom the disc as
a whole in the middle and so the light
can't make it through this sick layer of
disc but it can make it up and then if
something is here that reflects it let's
say piece of ice then it goes into your
direction you can see it is the disc
itself relevant to the formation of the
young
star that's what I'm working on so yes
it is yes it is no no no no need to
apologize right yes it is that's a
reasonable question that's a question
you should totally write an answer
proposal and find out now we know some
about about already so we probably have
to a little more than than let's do that
um but at this
stage most of the mass is already in the
in the star but if you look at our Earth
today right there's only planets left
and the dis is gone and so we can
measure or calculate how massive is that
dis and what Mass do we have in our
planets like just take the mass of Mars
and Earth and Jupiter and Saturn and add
them up and it's only about one% of the
mask of an average dis so where does the
rest of the Mask go well some of it
falls into the star and some of it
evaporates off and what fraction goes
where well that's what we try to measure
right and that influences the star in
some way how exactly depends a little
bit on the star it could change for
example the chemical composition because
these disc I said are made of ice and
dust does the gas like helium and
hydrogen does it evaporate off first and
all the metals Clump together and make
planets do all the metals then fold in
the star to mostly the gas falls into
the star that that's what we want to
measure okay here's a couple more images
here's images of jets and I already
talked about proper motion where you see
things move on the sky this is the star
famous star called
hh30 and the stars in the middle and you
see the disc on the side again and then
you have like this jet this really cated
stream of stuff going up and down and
here we can measure how fast it's going
out from the start we because we have
pictures from 1995 1998 and 2000 and so
you can take like this Dot and measure
how far is this Dot from the Star and
then you can look at the same dot three
years later and see how far away from
the star is it now and how far away from
the star is it
now and if you know how way how fast the
way that thing is how far away it is
then you can calculate how fast it moves
and it's around 300 miles per
second and that tells us well you know
we can take this star and we can look at
the gravitational energy and say where
does it come from it this jet is not
formed in the dis because this doesn't
have enough energy to make anything that
fast so this jet must be coming from
very very close to the star and so the
material that's thrown out of the jet is
stuff that's that's from the star or
that's at least from the inner edge of
the disc it's not something further
out now I'm not going to give you the
answer to everything right because I
first of all I don't know it we also
still do research on that and there's
also there's literally hundreds of
people researching that and I can't tell
you everything that hundreds of people
have spent the last 50 years working on
in in 30 minutes right but uh that gives
us information about where that material
comes
from now this is a jet that I've looked
at and this is one of those cases where
I said images don't necessarily look
good so this is observed for a Chandra
x-ray
telescope and every dot every gray dot
here every light gray dot is one Photon
one piece of
light every dark ray God is two pieces
of light and every black one is three
pieces of
light uh so this is each of those images
is about a day of looking at that star
you don't see the star itself the Stars
where these little axes are or you
barely see that the star itself because
again it's one of those cases where we
are looking through the disc from the
side and then we are we are interested
in the jet that comes up I showed you
that picture before how the jet moves
how this jet moves in the optical obser
hble we would like to know if the Jets
that we see in x-ray also move so first
of all we need to find one and then we
need to find a feature that moves look
in this gray box here in 2001 there's
one piece of
light in 2005 there's 1 2 3 four five
six seven photons pieces of light and
then in 2009 there's only two so I think
that means there is material that came
from the start that wasn't there in 2005
that moved into that position in 2009
and then it cooled off and so it moved
out and cooled off so we can't see it
anymore now that's that's from you know
two and seven photons and pieces of
light uh so so we try our best but but
if you want to make a pretty picture in
multiple different
images go ahead right it's going to be
hard but that's why yeah depending on
what research you do and what you look
at sometimes it looks good and sometimes
it doesn't so what we find is from from
stuff like this the things that this the
Jets that shine in x-rays are faster
than the ones that shine in in the
optical and what we think that means is
that jets are not like a homogeneous
stream it's actually layers of streams
like the layers of an onion there's
something in the middle that's faster
and then there's an outer layer that's a
little slower and a layer further out
that's a little slower and a layer
further out that's a little slower than
that until until you get like a very
slow
out to where the disc
is and again that tells us where the
disc coming from is it coming from Star
is it coming from disc we can measure
those
things okay back to the Rin nebul Cloud
I think I've showed that picture a
couple of times now in different images
I've talked about all the
pieces here's an x-ray
movie so this is a months of looking at
the r nebul Cloud you see that it's
twinkling and you see that some of them
change colors every one of these Dot is
a star and you see that they're becoming
brighter and fainter I should first star
say when you look with your eye and you
see stars
twinkling that doesn't mean anything
it's because the earth atmosphere is in
the way if you had to take your eyes
into space and look straight into space
well okay you die because you need to
breathe and but apart from that stars
wouldn't sprink uh would with very very
few exceptions they wouldn't twinkle
it's the twinkling is a motion of gas
between us in the Earth's atmosphere
wind and high layers that refract the
light and break it so it's actually very
annoying when you do telescope
observations on the ground you have to
try to correct that but in x-ray stars
become brighter and
fainter significantly like sometimes
they become 20 times
brighter and so you see things appearing
here that when even there before we can
show that in a different way and that
different way is what we call a light
curve
so what we do is we have the time at the
bottom in this case in a unit called
kiloseconds right because that's what
you do you do meters centimeters and
kilometers that'll be clearly there'll
be grams and kilograms so that'll be
seconds and
kilos but whatever and so we measure how
bright it is at this time where we start
measuring and then we measure how bright
it's here and how bright it's here how
bright it's here and we measure how
bright it's there and it suddenly
becomes a lot brighter and we call that
a stellar flare see that's in the X-ray
sometimes you see the the optical
although the optical they're not as
strong like you wouldn't they're so weak
you wouldn't see them with your B eyes
uh why how do we know what that means
well be great if there was a star nearby
where we could see what those things
actually mean turns out there is one and
we see it every day it's a sun so here's
a similar event on the
sun this is taken with a satellite
called
sdo and you see these Arc Loops here
now I've picked one where these arls
happen to be on the side of the sun
because then you can see it much better
than when it's in the middle and the Sun
is
Behind These are magnetic field lines
the sun is a magnetic field and there's
essentially like a North Pole over here
and a South Pole over there and then
along these magnetic field lines the gas
can heat up and when it heats up this is
a movie Taken in the
ultraviolet then becomes hot enough to
shine in the ultraviolet so I play it
again and you see that the depending on
what the magnetic field lines do more
and more of these arcs can light up and
so you can imagine if I take the entire
image together and just say how bright
is that image all over without knowing
where it's are now it's brighter than
when I started the movie so we can look
at the sun where we have actually a lot
of detail how these flares go and then
say okay it's probably happening very
similar on other stars except other
stars are brighter and the magnetic
fields are stronger and like slight we
can we can compare them here's another
one so we call a coronal mass injection
is stuff flying out of the sun matter
flying out of the sun now you might
imagine if if that hits the
planet that might do something to the
planet right and so their iPhone in fact
it does uh these these particle these uh
coronal mass ejections when they hit the
earth the earth has a magnetic field and
the magnetic field of the earth Shields
us from most of that but the really
strong of those effects the really
strong of those things they can knock
out satellites they disrupt Satellite
Communication if they were even stronger
the strongest one that Earth has
experienced called the car event after a
guy named caran who wrote a lot about it
um that was uh in in the late 1800s
shortly after the US the first
telegraphy lines and the magnetic field
wobbled so much that the telegraphy
lines like started giving Sparks in all
directions and people got hurt like from
from standing close to the machines now
if you imagine doing that to the
internet today like where we have far
more connected and have far more data
lines and have like electric wires
everywhere it's not clear what that will
do to us we just hope it doesn't happen
that's an important part but so
understanding Stell activity How likely
these events are how big they are how
can we prevent them does have uh
practical applications to us
to okay another thing we can do is we
can do Spectra we can look at Spectra
another tool and so Spectra is just the
color this is the spectrum of the
sun if you look at the sun closely
enough and then you put it through a
prism or through like May split it out
into rainbow or you know 10 years ago I
would tell people to take a CD uh and
sprinkled rainbows everywhere if you
look close enough you're going to find
these black lines in them they're called
frown hofner lines after a guy named
frof now who discovered them first and
it turns out each of those lines is
specific to a specific element so this
one for example is sodium in the orange
here and that has something to do with
how you know an an atom has a nucleus
and has electrons around it and the
electrons go like one level up or one
level down and that's a specific change
in energy and every specific change in
energy is a specific color of
light fortunately we can do the same
experiment at home or in the lab and we
can measure which element goes with
which color and then we can say oh this
star has a lot of a very strong line a
very strong dip or by where we expect
sodium so this star must have a lot of
sodium you can in fact do some of those
experiments at home if you have a gas
stove you know the flame is blue and if
you take some sodium chloride or salt if
you take some salt and dribble it in the
flame will become Orange it's a great
experiment for kids great I mean an
adult has to do it right because they
get pretty close to the pretty close to
the flame but that's the closest you'll
see Atomic physics like in your kitchen
and so we do that for a bunch of
elements and compare that to what we
measure in the lab and then it can tell
us what elements are stars made of and
so we know the sun has mostly hydrogen
and has some sodium it has iron it has
lithium and has all sorts of things and
we can measure how much does this star
have how much does that star have does
it change with the age of the star does
it change with the star having planets
or not having planets we can compare
those
things this is a spectrum how it looks
on the x-rays and there's other elements
and I just want to show you that you
know that's how they look I don't want
to go through every new line and tell
you what they do I just want to show you
some some data that I have personally
worked on so get an idea of how it looks
that means most of my work looks like
this now astronomers do not wear lap
codes and we don't work all at night
very very rarely people actually use
telescopes I mostly use space telescopes
so I don't ever get to look through them
or I don't ever get to go anywhere uh
people I work with some of them use
groundbased telescopes like in Chile for
example unfortunately we don't have to
fly to Chile for that anymore like
people used to fly to Hawaii to use a
telescopes in Hawaii and while I would
love to go to Hawaii at some point
people tell me if you go 10 times a year
it's not fun
anymore because you fly out from here
you're 12 hours off 12 hours jetl right
you you have one day to get used to
Hawaii then you get to the bottom of the
Mountain uh then you have a day to get
up the mountain then you need to get
Jack likeed by another 12 hours because
now you suddenly have to work at
night because that's when you use your
telescopes right and then you do it all
in Reverse again and so people would fly
to a why or to Chila for like just one
night of observations and that's not
just expensive and a pain it's also a
huge carbon emission and I'm very glad
we have the internet today and don't
have to do that very often anymore
sometimes you do like if you build your
own instrument with very specific
instrumentation you need to go and screw
it on the telescope then you need to be
there right but for many cases uh many
things can be REM done remotely and and
I most of the data all the data from
space all the data NASA has taken you
can go and download it's all public it's
all free I'm not sure it's useful to you
because the file format might be a
little bit obscure but you can can do
that and so I work in an
office um I've write code most of my
time I've write python code or I've
write WR text that that's my
job okay specifically for space
telescopes I said um and I know I'm
running five minutes over but I'm almost
done um so the way Hubble works or chva
works right there's only one Hubble and
it's not owned by any particular person
so how do we get to use it we
essentially once a year NASA inv writes
proposals so we write a letter that
essentially goes like this dear NASA I
would like to look at IM am loop I think
IM am Loop is a really cool star okay A
little better than that IM am Loop is a
star that is older than younger than tww
Hydra and that has signs of a dis of
accretion we've looked at tww Hydra
before and we want to know if if what
we've seen there if that's true for all
young stars or only for stars that are
10 million years old and if younger
Stars behave slightly different then I
go that and I send it in and some group
of people is going to look at that
because every year NASA gets people
asking for about 9 years or eight years
of data now there's only 365 nights a
year so there's only so much you can do
about it so people there's some
committee that ranks them says this is
the most likely and this is crap idea
and this won't work technically and this
one we like but we just didn't have any
time
left and so you send it in for chanra
you send it in in March then in June you
get an email back that says sorry we're
not going to do it and we aren't going
to do it because uh you didn't really
describe uh how long you need to look or
something like that so next march and
the second year you can update your
proposal you can send it in again and
explain that better let's say the second
time the committee accepts
it now that goes in annual Cycles right
your star isn't even visible all the
time because sometimes it's behind the
Sun and stuff like that so the stuff
that gets approved in June gets observed
sometime between August and the August
the year after so depending on how that
falls and this this particular case it
took even after I sent it in it took a
year and two months for me to get that
data then I take that data and I observe
it and I analyze it um took me a couple
of months to think about what it really
means and then I've write it up in a
journal and now I go and say okay maybe
we need to look at a star that's even
younger or that's an age between ion
Loop and T Hydra that has a higher mass
or lower Mass or something like that and
then I write another proposal why did I
tell you this well a that means the
timeline is very very long between when
you start when you have an idea what you
want to look at until you actually do
it's even hard to squeeze into a single
PhD and second that's why most of us
work on at least a dozen project at the
same time because after I've wrote this
in year one it's not like I twiddled my
thump between March that year and March
next year right I had need to have other
things to
do set that already okay and then like
we we try to interpret it in this
particular case this is IM Loop there's
these flares here in the UV and there's
FL in the x-rays here that suddenly
becomes a lot brighter and so that tells
us something about the magnetic field of
this St and then what do we do with
these results well we tell people about
it um short moment uh one of the things
we do is we go to conferences where it
be hundreds or dozens of astronomers and
they work on some of them work on radio
observations some of them work on
optical observations and you looked at I
looked at I'm Loop in the x-rays you
looked at I'm Loop in the radio you
learned something about the disc I
learned something about the star how
does it fit together so one of the
things do is they give a talk like I do
now although usually not as long it's
often just 10 minutes or so because you
don't have to explain all the way around
because everybody there has worked on
young stars for at least five years or
we make it a poster where we just write
the stuff so that you can grab your
colleagues and say hey come come over
here come come look what I did and then
say look what I did and then then we
hold it next to each other and then
ultimately we've write it in a
publication we communicate a lot by
email with other people and then uh we
write it into what we call publication a
paper although we call it paper it's not
on paper none of them is printed anymore
they sto printing 5 years ago it's all
electronic on you a question or remark
so
um when you get to use the telescope for
some amount of time um only you can use
it and that's because
the NASA amount of data you get is a
very small slice of the
sky for most
telescopes the answer depends a little
bit on the telescope but usually and so
when I say used for the chanra Space
Telescope or Hubble what I do is I fill
a web form that says look at this star
with this camera for that long and then
I don't actually have to know where that
stars on Sky I can't tell you where I am
lupus it's in lupus I don't know where
lupus is it's probably in the southern
hemisphere somewhere I think it is I
hope it is um but somebody else like
takes care of that because it's not like
any random person can move use a
joystick and move Hubble around right uh
this groundbased telescope that's a
little different specifically if you go
like you are a little close to the
controls and you can actually press a
button that make the thing
rotate okay so uh just before the end
what can you do right if you if you care
for astronomy well one important thing
is to be excited uh to like it to to
listen to me and other people and find
out what's about you can observe the sky
yourself we greatly appreciate if the
sky stays dark because it's much easier
to see when it's dark outside than when
it's light uh so for example around in
Arizona there's an observatory on kit
peek that used to be a fantastically
dark sky but Suburban developments and
in particular big box shopping malls are
coming closer and closer and closer and
for some reason all those parking lots
need to be lit 247 and most of them are
lit with lights that don't just Shine
Down that also shine up that's a problem
uh more recently
starlink if you want to launch 20,000
satellites in the sky they're going to
Vis through our pictures they're already
do I mean on x-rays we are fine because
they don't emit X-rays and also our
x-ray satellites are even further out
but with optical telescope you
constantly have images where there's
just streaks of right through because
there all these satellites going
through um pay taxes right because
that's what pays our salary that what
they said satellites are expensive and
um there's amateur astronomers who we
sometimes work this this is one as RW
Rogers a star and this is again a light
curve in different bands which is by the
different colors and different filters
and so those are people who just are
interested in astronomy they observe
this star some of them every night some
of them only every now and then and then
they upload how bright it was when they
looked at it in that
database and even years later I can go
and say now I have something interesting
about how RW I wonder what it did in the
last couple of years before and I pull
this data and say
oh this isn't actually the first time it
suddenly became dimmer it already went
very dim over here I wonder what that
means right but if nobody looks I
wouldn't have known there's also things
so you can go through act other
astronomical data and help like look at
classify like on an iPhone app and say
this looks like two stars there's one
over here and one over
here whereas in other pictures there's
only one and why does it matter well
with a good camera we can see is two pen
stars is a good resolution if you look
in this infrared telescope where
everything is a little more washed out
you might these two stars might shine
together and so you see it's bright but
it's actually bright because it's two
stars it's not because the one is bright
so there's programs like that uh where
you can do observations or look at
observations if you want okay stars form
a large molecular clouds uh young stars
are surrounded by dis in this this we
form planets or that stars form planets
we don't but we observe Planet formation
uh young stars have these powerful
outflows these jets that drive stuff
into space uh star formation happens
right now now in the Milky Way it's not
over even though Earth is old stars and
planets are still forming almost
everywhere and we do many different
observations we use different telescopes
so we can look at different wavelengths
we can look at different aspects so
better understand how that works and are
you able to see stars for other G as
well yes I mean I don't because I
specialize on stars in our galaxy and
that in other galaxies they're just so
far away that it's hard to see so in
other galaxies you only see the
brightest and most massive stars things
like our sun you wouldn't see in a
different galaxy
but things that are 100 times as massive
as a sun you V so things like our sun
you don't see individually but if
there's many of them you see them all
mush together right so we we know that
that happens we know that star form in
other galaxies we have these mush
together images I personally study
things where I can like say that I can
look at individual stars and get instead
of many thousands of stars and do a
sample and comp like do a statistic over
them I look at individual stars that you
can look at in great detail so I don't
but in principle do
yeah this is a little farfield do you
know anything about that there's a gr
student I think in New Orleans I saw
this a new story in BBC who discovered
the cluster of galaxies in a structure
of a ring and she said that it's
significant because it um um it
threatens the uh belief that's that's
basis for the standard model of particle
physics that with a uniform I read that
too did you read did you hear about this
I read that too but I don't know any
more about it than what was in the news
what was in the newspaper article okay I
was just yeah I can say a couple more
things I have a couple of thoughts of
that but let me let me go if there's
anything that's related to this to this
talk first and
then if is that I mean if nobody else
has any questions I can say a few things
but no okay then thanks for coming you
know you're welcome to you're welcome to
stay and talk with me as long as you
want but you also don't have to feel
obliged to sit in your desk just because
I'm in your chair just because I'm I'm
talking because I I know I've already
run over so feel free to run
[Applause]
off so the the basic idea is that in the
early Universe right we have the big
bang and so stuff stuff starts
expanding um but uh but if something if
if you had a structure let's say a ring
or disc or not a disc like this but it
like some material of thousands of
galaxies
something over here and over here if
they look the same if they're connected
how do they actually talk to each other
because a million years after the big
bang light can only make it a distance
of a million light
years so if if let's say this today like
in my my my my scar forming regions
right star if there's a bright star It
Shines on this star it illuminates it
this star evaporates and that all makes
sense but
but if this star can't see this one
because because the universe isn't old
enough for the light to go from here to
there how would this St know anything
about this one could there just be
something in the structure of SpaceTime
itself that organizes how we we think or
the the current idea is that information
nothing can travel faster than the speed
of light gravitational waves don't
travel faster the structure of space
time doesn't travel faster than the
speed of light so any structure that's
bigger then the the age of the universe
times the speed of light at the time
when it was formed shouldn't be there oh
you're arguing that's the that's the
basic idea of the basic problem right uh
and so uh the headline I read from that
article I think I read on the New York
Times instead of BBC so the text is
slightly different right but it's based
on the same press release that's from
the conference last week in in New
Orleans um the basic idea is that they
argue that the structure is older is so
old that at the time light didn't have
enough time to travel from one end to
the other over the age of the universe
at the time so that structure shouldn't
have formed because the universe like
there was no way information could have
communicated around no the inflationary
model of the universe isn't doesn't the
universe expand fast it does but it does
so for the first like billions of a
second or something like that or
millions of a second like there wouldn't
be galaxies galaxies now I don't work on
early cosmology so maybe it's a Millions
maybe it's hundred thousands of second
but it's it's tiny it's it's too early
for
that there there's multiple other things
that could be going on and and I don't
know and I'm sure these people have
looked into that but I don't know one
thing that has happened in the past is
that people see structures where there
aren't
any it's this ring looks this ring looks
very good you know but if I were to just
throw throw like chalk pieces on the
chalkboard and you didn't know how I
made that you're probably going to find
some structure in there you just need to
look at the night Sky people see you
know the Orion Orion there or they see
Leo or they see you know and that
clearly isn't a line up there and those
stars have nothing to do with each other
because and we see them on the sky that
even stars that look close on the sky
one of them is over here and the other
one is like far out over there they have
nothing to do with each other so the eye
our eye is trained to recognize patterns
now people know that and there are
statistical tests you can try to do that
I'm sure the people who wrote this
article have done that um but it's it's
cly thing people will look into very
carefully and say what's the probability
of that just being by chance right now I
the image I saw in the press in these
Rings looks pretty good um but I haven't
seen the original images and I'm not an
expert in that field so I said I'll give
you some thoughts but I don't have an
authorative answer right I mean if you
uh imagine going from you know from this
image to something that looks more
like looks more like uh I'm looking for
drawing looks more like this there's
some processing that happened in between
to that that we we not cheating in the
sense that for
example like why is a near infrared red
and blue like our eyes can't see near
infrared right so we need to assign a
color to it like the doctor does when
you do X-rays of a broken hand they
print it in black and white or they
could print it in red and blue or
whatever color they like we just need to
print it in some color scale that the
eye can see because x-rays aren't they
aren't red or blue or
white they're just X-rays and our eye
can't see them so they don't have a
color they have x-ray color but we can't
see that so just like an Instagram
filter that everything you can turn
everything that's green into blue and
everything that's blue into green you
can do that right and so we turn
everything that's x-rays into green and
everything that's mid infrared into blue
or something and so that's processing
that happens to make it visible um yeah
you have to make sure that processing is
right and I'm sure the people who did
the research tried that but then when
you just see the image on the BBC it's
probably the more processed version so
you would want to see how the less
processed version looks like right what
we're see it I don't know I don't know
which image they used I just say there's
many steps in between and if you want to
understand the details you have to look
at all those steps and I haven't done
that and so I'm going to stop
speculating now right because I don't
know any more than that
making many steps so we can't just look
at an image and think that's what we
would see if we were you know about the
about I mean we not know we didn't we
didn't draw these images we didn't make
them up but we clearly manipulated them
to make things more visible and stand
out the same way as you would you know
when you post something on Instagram you
put a filter that softens it or
highlights the background or you know uh
reduces like that that solar glare and
gives you the more details in the in the
faint Parts all that highlights the
solar glare and and removes all the
details in the faint part so there there
steps in between depending on what you
want to look
at so actually not the colors See like
accurately if we ever go to the space
it's not that it's going to it's not
going to look like that part of that is
like so even the visible
light this is using a 2 point this is
Hubble there a 2.4 met
telescope whereas your the pupil of your
eye is about this
big and Hubble looked at that for about
an hour hour or two hours or something
like that and so you collect all this
light from a very for a very long period
of time using a really big mirror if you
look the same way with your eye you're
going to just see the light that
instantly arrives in this
area and you can test that by looking at
something you can see with your eye go
out where it's dark and look at your R
nebula and um while I tell you that the
I have the r nebula somewhere while I
tell you that this is the r NE
it's not going to look like that when
you look with your eye it's going to be
a little fuzzy thing like um add another
image now this is a little
closer but but go to the other end of
the room and take your glasses
off and that's probably closer to what
you would see with your naked
eye but that's you know that's like on
Earth you use a magnifying glass that
doesn't mean it's fake it's which means
it's seen through a magnifying class or
you know in your and my case through our
glasses right when I see I see you
better this way that doesn't mean it's a
fake image it just means I see you
through your glasses whereas now I don't
and so similarly like there's there's
magnifying there's longer exposures and
there is Filters that like think of it
as polarizing glasses that take out the
solar glare that doesn't mean doesn't
mean it's fake it just means I'm or
sunglasses he use sunglasses to make it
a little darker so your eyes can see it
better now the same thing we can do with
telescopes doesn't mean it's wrong it
just means it's seen through a
filter and thear looking
ater this this has thousands of young
Stars the one you were looking at I so
the ones I've looked at aren't actually
on this picture the ones I've
personally uh I work on some R nebula
but I they sit they I don't know where
they are they're probably over here so I
work on X-rays and this is like anal
image this is an optical image but are
they in that area some of them are in
that area but the Orion Nebula is
already um it's a little it's not far
away uh but I since I want to study
individual stars for as much detail as I
can I look for the closest one to look
at that near the belt of the IR there a
lot of young young
stars that is true that is a good hot
spot for in fact showed you where it was
yeah you show us where it
was in Orion's nebula that's what is
that's it that's
not star looking at I've looked at
dozens of stars in different locations
including talking I am Loop no I am
lupus in Lupus if it wasn't a rine it
would be called something something Orie
oh got it okay so the STS the brightest
one is a Ori the second brightest is B
Ori C Ori D Ori and then you know
sometimes sometimes they just get a
number if they variable they start with
V and then it's V1 12748 or or something
like
that okay thank you can I ask you
something she said what is important to
have this connection between the St so
you were mentioning that in the
formation of the the UN so you have two
that they might be connected or have
connection why is that important and so
I mean is it important we try to find
out what it is right the universe is
what it is we're not going to make a new
universe um but in this particular case
that and it wouldn't be Stars it' be
galaxies but I mean the same idea you
have two objects and if these two
objects can't talk to each other because
there wasn't enough time for them to
exchange light or information no
information travels faster than light we
think if there was no time to exchange
information there shouldn't be there
shouldn't be related to each other they
should have formed
independently because how if they
related to each other let's say if this
star like it this Stars right if this
star evaporates that one light needs to
have time to go from this one to that
one otherwise it can't evaporate it if
the light can't make it because the
universe isn't old enough yet now this
AR going to be stars because the
universe grows pretty fast so it's going
to be galaxies that talk to each other
but the same idea is if if they form
like a structure like a perfect ring on
the
sky then that ring must have formed we
think at a time when when there was some
event that made that ring I don't know
explosion in the middle or something
that that made them all form at the same
time or something like that if the if
these structure formed that the Universe
was so young that that nothing could
have gone between here from there why
are they on this perfect
ring what what made them go on that ring
like that should be randomly located and
the probability of randomly making a
ring or randomly making a triangle
whatever you want is pretty low so if
you find structures that look as if
there's some some causality some cause
that made this
structure then the universe should have
been old enough that that cause can
actually like propagate information from
I don't know an explosion or whatever it
is from from where that let's take an
explosion as an example right let's say
there's an explosion in the middle and
the shock wave that comes out and that
forms
something then that can only happen if
the UN when it Formed if the universe
was old enough for the shock wave to
actually go from the middle to the
outside otherwise that won't work like
so if if there's nothing can go from the
middle to the outside how would we get
like a perfect ring of galaxies and that
inflationary rate of expansion was too
too far in the past to to have accounted
for that their exist that there's
certainly things that are related to
that there's some things called Baran
acoustic oscillations that have to do
with this inflation but I'm not an
expert on inflation and I'm not going to
derive you know the equations of the
inflationary Universe on the Blackboard
now maybe alth will will respond at some
point maybe I like this particular press
release from last week I'm sure lots of
people are going to look at respond yeah
we keep
our
attention focused okay thank you thank
you thank you thanks for
coming